hello and welcome to this blitz video
files ik mark my opponent is that no
information ok a little bit legging
so probably scotch four nights we get so
this is good news okay yeah well him a
couple of lines are good yeah this is
this is good we're just wondering if you
have something better but this is the
standard way to go about it and it is
strong just push all those pawns ok g5
form how are we going to do it
yeah g5 will open up more files I think
this is going to be right no black ball
black is not able to take this but it's
hard to believe that this is going to
work I have Queen h2 h7 checkmate it's a
simple yet I think quite effective idea
here I'm also threatening f5 winning a
piece that's an additional problem quite
typically black has not spend any time
like no time it is already lost
I know it's too late to think okay if I
go f5 you can take take rookie three
Queen III Bishop g5 that's not good so
we have to do it in a different way
let's see how let's see how Queen h2 is
a simple continuation that is probably
not bad let's do that he more or less
has to play g6 I believe
okay now if I go five pawn takes Queen
h7 King f8 Bishop c5 will win let's do
it of course it does not have to take 25
but yeah Bishop g7 is not a move that
scares us a lot so still I can check you
can also take on d6 not totally certain
what's best here he doesn't really have
a great move now so let's take it
rook takes g6 mm-hmm well such an easy
decision yeah Queen c7 maybe it was but
it's still okay Bishop d4 may be
threatening made on h8 looks strong
the takes it rook takes I'm still
threatening made on a jade
maybe has a tricky move Knight f6 oh
okay again I have check one how to do it
in I can also check here which will
force him to e7 check again King f8
rogue edge ages
that's not help that will not survive
and here sorry my voice is a bit of 94
will win huh
you know a bit down a long time but a
position is too bad
yeah it's just over
and that cap Shonda form you get that
really quite a lot then it is pretty bad
I lost the first game against this guy
hmm looks like I had a good position Dan
spawn yeah that's not happening here
yeah I'm so pleased letting the clock
run down yeah Black has to avoid to take
him on d4 I don't think that after this
you can get a decent game anymore the
white queen is very strong and this idea
Bishop e3 f3 long castles like this this
is this it's just going to be very
strong and very simple it's like the
game plays itself for white and black
has no particular counter play so he
lets it run down you know I don't know
so d60 played and you have these these
simple simple choices and now he
actually has moved yeah okay
so yeah here the problem is just my
moves like automatic moves and black has
no counter play you should probably
don't play h6 in which which helps me a
lot
giving me a hook but it's like this this
is a move that he played instantaneously
and I mean this is good enough to lose a
game age six bad enough
ya know g5 it's not really a pawn second
it's like what you do him for and things
are really ugly by now it's plus three
yeah I wonder about the conversion yeah
clean edge tool if I played in the rest
way yeah f5 I was irritated a bit by
this but okay I have this and Bishop h6
which is winning totally of course yeah
that that wasn't miss then now then f5
was stronger it's it's funny that here
taking I mean I have to look at this
idea yeah okay but II five should also
win her they are plus five I came yeah
this is not the best but I don't see
black surviving this anyway Queen c7 and
Bishop t4 should be enough no I'm not
threaded screen h8 so if he takes that
is the mate yet he took on the form look
takes and yeah just nothing to do yeah
it's mate mate it axiom yeah you're just
not coming back from the opening I think
this is not saying that's losing but
it's it's giving white a very good game
with no problems to solve
okay guys thanks for watching